[MUSIC PLAYING]
TERRENCE RYAN: Hi,
my name's Terry Ryan.
I am a developer
advocate for Google.
So let's get started.
There are a ton of GCP products.
When I went to go put
this talk together,
I went to go to our canonical
list of all of our products
to like, OK, what things
should I talk about?
And so I went and I saw these.
And then I saw these.
And I was like, oh, what did I
sign up for here in this talk?
I can't get through all of this.
Oh, and there are the open
source ones that we also
do a lot with.
So I can't get
through all of this.
So what is my goal
here with this talk?
My talk is to give a tour of GCP
from the perspective of someone
coming to GCP for
the first time.
So what are these things?
What are all these hexagons?
What do they all mean?
A secondary goal, but not
something I'm going to get to,
is explaining all the
various things that
are available on Google Cloud.
I just literally cannot do it.
And a lot of this, there are
a lot of individual slides
I have here that are actually
placeholders for an entire talk
I give somewhere else.
Like when I get into
compute serverless
versus VM versus containers.
That's a whole talk
on unto itself.
So I'm going to try to point you
all in the direction of where
you want to find the
things that you want to do,
and hopefully that will be
good for everyone in the room.
So one of the resources that
I used to build this content
is GCP in four
words or less, which
is available at that
very long GitHub address.
If you just do a
search on a search
engine of your choice for GCP in
four words, you will find this.
And it's really helpful.
It gives very
concise definitions
of a lot of our products.
And where they are concise, I
hopefully, will kind of help
explain them.
So let's get
started with I think
one of the most important
parts of GCP, which
is infrastructure.
When you move your work over
us, you need to run somewhere,
you need to have VMs, you need
to have network connectivity,
you need basic
computing resources.
So infrastructure is a gigantic
important part of this story.
Oh, a little bit
about me, just so
you kind of see
where my biases are.
I am by definition a
AppDev mostly on the web.
So you'll see that I
have much more knowledge
on the compute side of the
house and the technologies that
sort of complement them as
opposed to say, oh, big data
jobs.
So I'm going to skip
this slight detour
and go right into computing.
And we'll talk about the
issue I already brought up,
is VM versus serverless
versus containers.
So this is one of the first
decisions you have to make.
Where are you going
to run the code
that you need to run to
do what you need to do?
So we start out first
with Compute Engine,
which is where I think a lot
of our customers start off.
Virtual machines,
disks and network.
What do they do?
What can they do for us?
So we will start.
Compute Engine, you
can get anywhere
from 0.5 to 96 processors.
And actually, you will
actually see in the UI
that you can go all
the way up to 160,
but you can't customize them.
Same thing with memory.
Half, just under half a
gigabyte RAM to 624 gigs of RAM.
You can attach up
to 64 terabytes
of standard disk or SSD.
You can do three
terabytes of attached SSD.
You can add GPUs or TPUs.
And I like to say they
speed up in tens of seconds.
You'll see that in a minute.
I'm just going to
go right to my demo,
and then if I could
switch over to my machine,
that would be great.
There we go.
All right, so you'll see here
I have a whole bunch of VMs
already, but I'm going
to create a new one.
And I'm going to have
to call it deleteme2,
because I created
one earlier today.
And let's see, we'll put
it, let's put it in LA.
All right, our Los
Angeles data center.
And you'll see that I can
go ahead and customize.
I can create with
anywhere from 96.
I can play around
with this, I'm just
going to do a basic
one, because I
don't want to have to explain
that on my expense report.
Let's say, I can
choose a whole bunch
of different images, a whole
bunch of different flavors
of Linux, CoreOS, Debian,
SUSE, whatever you want to use.
And we have flavors
of Windows as well.
I could use standard or
persistent, sorry, SSD
persistent disk or
standard persistent disk.
Again, I will say to standard.
And we see that I get an
estimate of how much it's
going to cost per month.
Great.
I can open up firewall for it.
But one of my favorite
features of the interface
here is down to the bottom.
I use this a lot.
I configure this in the web.
And then I hit this, and I get--
you'll see it's a
long string of text,
but this is the G
Cloud scripting command
to build the VM
that I configured.
So I can use the tool to
dial in exactly what I want.
And then I don't
have to write out
these really super
long URLs that
mean something in
terms of what scopes
the VM is able to access.
I don't have to
remember all of that.
The tool will do it for me.
But I'm going to go
ahead and create this VM.
And like I said, these VMs
spin up in tens of seconds,
which means when I'm in
my hotel room practicing,
making sure I don't
screw up in front of you
all, takes like 10 seconds.
In front of people
it takes like 40,
and I'm not really sure why.
But my hope is that as I slowly
crab walk over to the console,
it'll be ready when I get there.
Ooh, it was!
All right, good.
So thank you for not looking
directly at the screen.
And you'll notice there I
pressed the button to SSH
into the machine.
That's available through
the console all the time.
I can just, I don't
have to pull down certs.
I don't have to set
up my own terminal.
If you want to, you can.
I don't want to.
I just do it.
I do all of my maintenance
through these browser windows.
And you'll see here that I'm
connecting, and by the time
I walk over here, it's all
ready to go and I can, you know,
let me bump up the
font a little bit
here so you can see that I'm
going to apt, get update.
All right, it starts
installing software.
Remember that I was
supposed to sudo that.
So sudo, bang bang.
Do it again, there we go.
And so now I've got a VM that I
can start fooling around with,
installing software on,
all ready to go right
through the browser.
So I'm going to switch back
to the preso and move on.
So that was Compute Engine.
Now I want to talk a little bit
about App Engine, four words
or less managed application
platform, Managed App Platform.
App Engine has two flavors,
standard and flexible.
And I think these
runtimes are off,
because I know PHP
can now do 7.2.
So I apologize for that.
So standard and flexible.
There is a little bit of
difference between the two.
Flexible, you can do more
different runtimes and more
different languages.
And it has open
capabilities, but it
it's not as scalable
as standard,
which is much more constrained.
You have to really
adapt your code style
to write for App Engine.
But you get incredibly
rapid scale out of it.
And it scales down to zero.
So if you're not using it,
you don't get charged for it.
And if you are using
it, you can scale up
to however much usage you need
to handle relatively quickly.
And I'm actually going to show
a demo of App Engine scaling
in just one second here.
So let me switch
over to my machine.
And I'm going to call
this up, hopefully.
Let's make sure
everything's loading.
There we go.
All right, so let me
explain what's going on
before I fire this off.
I have an App Engine app.
You'll see it up the top UI.
That's this thing.
This is going to--
I give it a variable
amount of load.
It's going to take that
load, distribute it,
basically do all the math to
divide it amongst the five
the VMs that I have down there.
Those five VMs
have Apache Bench,
and they're just
going to hit, they're
going to send a whole bunch
of requests against the app
down there at the bottom, a
totally real app, appspot.com.
The reason why that's
obscured for now
is because I want
to show this cold.
So I tested this last night
and I let it all go cold.
It's been sitting
idle for overnight.
It has zero usage right now.
I want to show you how
fast App Engine can
scale from not running
at all to handling
large amounts of traffic.
So up here at the
top, you'll see that I
have a request of 10,000.
So I'm going to send 10,000
requests at that totally real
service there at the bottom.
We're going to go
ahead and send load.
And you'll see App
Engine's speeding up
instances of my code
to handle my requests.
And oh, something got
interrupted there.
So let me just,
ignore that happened.
Huh, I seem to be having
issues with this demo today.
Maybe I, no wait, yeah, no, I'm
going to give it one more try
and then say I should have
tested this morning in addition
to last night.
Yeah, all right,
yeah, fair enough.
All right.
Well then, I'm just going to
punish it by sending 100,000,
200,000 at it.
So I think what's happening
is one of my VMs is down.
Oh no.
OK, fair enough.
Well, normally App Engine
can scale beautifully
when the app I wrote to
show this off shows up.
What you should see,
and what I will totally
go back and make sure is working
the next time I give this talk,
is that usually it will
go and scale however
many operations I
need it to take.
And it will, in the
beginning, the QPS there, you
see at the top, it's
at 3,600, will be low.
It will be like 500, because
it's warming up from cold.
And then I can eventually
get this up to being able
handle QPSs of 8,500.
QPS, which when you
do all the math,
is about 30 million requests an
hour or what Wikipedia handles.
I am sure App Engine is fine.
I am sure I pushed a
change at some point that
broke this front end.
So with that, I'm going to
switch away from the demo
and be glad that my
sacrifice to the demo gods
did not get accepted
this morning.
So let's, oh, we're
going to go this way.
Let's go forward.
So now I want to talk
about Cloud Functions.
You talked about
App Engine, which
is an application as a service.
You build an application,
we scale it for you.
But sometimes you don't
need a full application,
you just need a
little bit of code.
One little bit of code
that will do one thing.
Enter Cloud Functions, event
driven serverless functions.
What you can do is have a
function, a single function,
respond to an event.
And that event
could be HTTP-based,
so you get a URL that you
can use to hit your code.
Or it could be something
what we call background.
Background is writing
a file to a bucket
or responding to a
message on Pub/Sub.
Languages, we have a restricted
set of languages here--
Node.js, Python and Go.
But this is another
one where I'm just
going to go to the console
and show it directly.
So if we could switch back here.
And have a little
bit of networking.
So I'm going to blame the
other one on the network
and just add wireless here.
All right, so we're going to
go ahead and create a function.
And what's cool is,
functions will automatically
populate this stuff for me.
So I can just call
this greetings.
And you'll see that it has a
hello world message down there.
I'll spell it
correctly, that helps.
I have a couple of
different options.
I'm going to make
this trigger on HTTP.
I'm going to call the
function, hello world.
And what's cool is, I
can experiment with this.
I can-- no, I'm all right.
Thank you though.
I'm more covering up
for my faults, sorry.
So I'm going to go
ahead and create this.
And an error occurred.
Fantastic.
Maybe I should've taken the
hard wire, but too late now.
So I already built one of these.
So I can-- I was
prepared for this.
So we'll see that I have a
function here all ready to go.
And I have a--
let's see, if we trigger this.
I can go ahead and
write this function
that was the same exact
function I just wrote there.
And we'll see.
Yeah, send something, would you?
All right.
So this takes about
30 seconds to deploy.
And I can have
functions that respond
to anything that I need, but
based on just one function.
So great, we're going to
switch back to the live preso.
And we'll talk a little
about Kubernetes Engine.
So we talked about VMs, we
talked about serverless,
and now we're going
to go with containers.
So how many people
here have played with--
how many people here
have played with Docker?
Good.
All right, that's normal.
How many people here have
played with Kubernetes?
set up their own Kubernetes
from scratch, the hard way?
OK, less.
All right, so here is what
Kubernetes Engine does for you.
So if you are used to
running Kubernetes,
you may recognize them.
So you go to set up
Kubernetes and you build
yourself a cluster of machines.
You want to make sure
you have attached disks
to the node machines,
because they're
going to need extra storage
to run your containers
and whatnot.
And then you're going to go
ahead and install Kubernetes
and wire up all the
connections to make
sure you have a network that
will allow all of them to talk.
You want to make sure
you have your nodes.
you have your masters.
You want to make sure they're
all talking to one another.
And then you're going to want to
add DNS and service discovery.
And then probably someone
will say, how do we
know stuff is running?
So you got to add
logging and monitoring.
And then you got to make sure
the OSs all stay up to date.
Then you got to make sure
Kubernetes stays up to date.
And that's just a
lot of work, right?
Like it's a lot of work.
I made it sound faster
and simpler than it is.
There's a whole [? doc ?]
that's Kubernetes the hard way
that breaks people
when they try to do it.
Or, just saying you could
go to Kubernetes Engine
and hit that button that says
Create Cluster and just press
it and it does all
of that for you.
And we will manage all
the updates for you.
All you have to do is say
update, and we'll update.
And that's a much
better experience
than running Kubernetes
the hard way.
And so I just want to real quick
show what Kubernetes engine can
do for you.
So I'm going to
switch to the laptop
here, and let's give
this another try.
So I have a Kubernetes Engine--
sorry, I have a Kubernetes
cluster already go.
And so the first thing
I'm going to do here
is launch a visualizer.
And I'm going to do
all this with Make,
because I don't want to live
type in front of anybody.
So let's make sure this
is all up and running.
Visualizer.
OK, we should see nothing here.
Good.
There's nothing.
All right.
What we're going to do is, we're
going to launch a Kubernetes
system here.
So let's make launch.
We should be able
to see this live.
No, make deploy.
Sorry, make deploy.
All right, stuff is happening.
So if we go back to here, we
should slowly see my containers
and my services load
up any moment now.
Yeah, there we go.
Good, good, good.
All right, so we
have containers.
I have a little
performance anxiety now.
So we see my
containers loading up.
I've got Drupal.
I've got Drupal 8.
I've got WordPress.
I've got custom PHP front end.
I've got a node app.
And all of this is running
on the same hardware.
It's all running--
like you would never
run Drupal and the Drupal 8
and Drupal 7 in the same box
or run a version of
Node on it, but that's
the great thing
about Kubernetes,
you have this set of
allocated resources
that you can just
keep adding containers
on until you fill it up.
And then with
Kubernetes engine, it
will actually scale it for you.
But I have the databases
all set up in the back end.
And I have all of the front
ends running and working.
So that was a system that wasn't
running at all two seconds ago,
and now I'm starting
a good IP addresses.
I'm starting to
get connectivity.
I am not going to risk it.
I going to say this
works and this is great.
So I'm going to switch
back to presentation mode.
And then we're going to talk
about something that got
announced today, which is
really exciting, Cloud Run.
Now Cloud Run sort of
straddles, because if I
were to give it four
names, four words,
it would be serverless
but with containers,
which seems sort of oxymoronic.
But basically, what you
get with Cloud Run is,
you get what we call
Knative, but managed--
Knative managed.
You give it any container and
we will scale it down to zero
or scale it up to however
much you need to do.
And we are able to
scale that under load.
So I'm going to show a quick
example of a Cloud Run app.
I going to show
two Cloud Run apps.
So one of the things--
I'm going to switch
back to my laptop here.
And let me make sure
that I have access.
And let me talk about a little
thing that I was trying to do,
which is, I have a
tab delimited file.
It's not that exciting.
It is all the
sessions from Next.
There's some extra
proprietary data in there,
so don't like read
it or anything else.
Trust me, it's all the
sessions from Next.
And I just want to take
it, display it on a screen.
So I wrote a little
Go app that does that.
And let's see.
We have that in Go--
sorry, in Run.
So me pull up Run here.
Do, do.
Here we go.
And let's see, here's my Go app.
And you'll see that
I have a URL for it.
All right.
So let's go click on that.
And we'll see the Next
2019 session list.
Great.
Right?
Just a little bit of code.
I'm not going to show it to
you, but it's not that exciting.
It's just string parsed in code.
But when I went
and looked at this,
we go down and then
eventually someplace,
it just kind of falls down.
Like the string
parsing in Go, I just
could not get it to do
what I needed to do.
So I struggled with
Go for a little while.
Then I remembered I'm old.
And I used to know
a language that
was really fantastic
at parsing strings,
really fantastic
at parsing strings.
But no one would build a
serverless runtime around Perl.
Right?
That seems ridiculous.
But I was like, but maybe,
maybe it would do better than Go
at parsing a tab delimited file.
So we'll see here.
I have the same app.
You'll see it is Perl.
You may not
recognize it as Perl,
because I did not write it to
be as inscrutable as possible.
But it works.
So I'm going to go
and deploy this code.
There we go.
We're going to
deploy that again.
All right, and
this time it works.
We're going to see how
long it takes to push
a container to Cloud Run.
So there we are.
And should be done now.
No?
Not going to work.
OK, good.
All right, so we can go
back to Cloud Run here.
We'll go back and we'll see that
I have a version of this Perl.
And I'm going to go
ahead and go to this API.
Oh, sorry.
No, no, main.pl
because that's ugly.
There we go.
And there we are.
We have the [INAUDIBLE] list up.
But happens if we scroll down?
Oh, look, look at that.
Perl did it perfectly.
Perl did it fantastically.
Now what I love
about this is, one,
I get to make fun
of Go, which I love.
I do love Go, but I do
like making fun of Gophers.
But the other thing here
is that, like we all
have this kind of
code lying around
that someone wrote 20
years ago and 10 years ago
and is still being maintained,
still needs to run,
and we would like to get
it off of our machines.
I got a, however old Perl
is now, running on Cloud Run
and solving my problems without
having to do a lot of work
to get Perl running
on Cloud Run.
So that's what I love.
Anything you bring to
Cloud Run will just run.
And that's really
fantastic and free.
All right, great.
So I am going to
go back to my preso
and go a little bit further.
And now we have a
question to ask.
It's like, which
do I choose, right?
Like I've got
containers, I've got VMs,
and I've got serverless.
Which one do I choose?
And that is, like I said,
an entire talk on its own.
But let me try to give you kind
of the bullet points of this.
If you've got a lot of
stuff in VMs and VMs
are the gravity that are
holding you to being on prem
and you want to move
to cloud, well then,
I would just go
with Compute Engine,
just do migrations
to VMs and fine.
Especially if you have a large
number of systems people,
if you're in a shop that's
more systems than dev,
it totally makes sense to go
to VMs and not switch over.
If you have a lot of
developers and you
have a lot of
Greenfield projects,
it's a lot easier to
start Greenfield projects
on serverless than it is to
start it on your own hardware.
So that would kind of lend
you towards going serverless.
If you have a good mix of both
systems people and developers,
and you're looking to get
the most out of the hardware,
to get the most out of your
spend for your resources,
container and Container
Engine is the way I would go.
And one of the advantages
of containerization
is, one, preparing your apps to
run on containers pretty much
matches what you need to do
to run them on serverless,
except the whole Docker part.
But especially with the
advent of Cloud Run,
running in containers, you can
choose to run on Kubernetes.
You can choose it
to run on Cloud Run.
You can choose to
run it on Docker.
You can choose to run on a whole
bunch of different platforms.
So when in doubt, I
would say containers
is probably the way
you want to go for now.
Serverless, I
think, is eventually
going to be what
everyone wants to do.
I think it is today what a
lot of developers want to do,
but there's things
blocking people from going.
But I think, so a lot of VMs,
stick with Compute Engine.
If you have a lot of
developers, go with serverless.
If you a lot of systems people
and a lot of developers,
you can go with containers
with the added thing
if you can learn
containers now, it
would make future transitions
for you much easier.
That's a lot condensed
into one slide.
All right, so I'm going to
switch gears here and now
talk about networking.
One of the things that we are
proudest about about Google
Cloud and our infrastructure, is
we have our own private network
so that when you
are transmitting
data between our services,
it transmits completely
on our network before it ever
touches the public internet.
And we can route stuff
all around the world.
So if you are a
user in Australia
and you request a resource
in North America, what's
going to happen
is, the request is
going to go to a local point of
presence in Australia for us,
and then travel along our
network to North America
and then back.
And what this does
is, it provides--
you get shielded from a
lot of the bursting nature
of internet traffic
because our network is
a little bit more consistent.
And you get pretty
good throughput
through that back end network.
And I actually want to show
a little demo of an app
that we built to kind
of show this off.
So if you could switch
back to the laptop.
OK, so what I'm going to
do is, I have a picture--
I have a head shot on my
desktop that I took earlier.
So there I am.
There's me.
We're going to send
me around the world.
So I'm going to send.
We're going to prepare,
we're connecting,
and then we're going to be able
to see this travel in real time
across our network.
Bam, we're done.
So that transmit, that going
from Taiwan to Tokyo to Sydney
to Oregon to Iowa to Virginia
to London to Frankfurt
to Sao Paulo, took 4.24
seconds on our network.
And what's great about the setup
that we have for this is, one,
that's fairly good
that we're able to send
this message across.
And we stamped it
in all the places.
We had a VM in
each location that
took the image in,
stamped it, and then
sent it onto the next spot.
But what's really
great about this,
is that I didn't have
to set up any networking
to make this happen.
If you have your VMs
in one of our projects,
they can automatically
talk to one another.
So you don't have to go to
different consoles or different
parts of the world.
You can just have all
of your VMs in one place
and wire them up to
talk to one another
just by adding them
to the same project.
If you want to play
with this, we actually
have a full version of this
out in the dev lounge--
sorry, the dev zone.
And you can actually get
selfies that print out
and your picture has
traveled around the world,
and you can take that
home as a souvenir.
So I'm going to switch
back to the preso.
I'm going backwards.
There we go.
All right, now some
basic things that people
want from the network here.
They want load balancers.
We have load balancers.
We divide them into
HTTP SSL, which
you would think of as more
than L7 load balancer.
We also have network
load balancers,
which is what you think
of as an L4 load balancer.
You can also set up
the load balancers
to be internal only so that
you can only have traffic--
you don't have to expose
your services to the world
to get them to be load balanced.
We have firewalls.
Pretty easy to set up.
You set up a rule,
open port 3306.
You give that rule
a name, MySQL.
You apply that tag,
that name to a machine,
and it'll open up that
port on that machine.
Relatively easy to do and
pretty simple to go through.
We also have Cloud
virtual network.
So if you want to configure
routes to handle communication
between your Google Cloud
instances and another location,
you can do that.
We have Cloud Interconnect.
If you have enough
traffic that you
would like to
directly peer with us,
that's something that
we can talk about.
It is obviously something where
there's a lot of upfront cost.
But the advantage is, is once
you start that pipeline going,
you can transmit
large amounts of data
for a better experience.
VPN.
We do provide VPN, but it's
gateway to gateway only.
This isn't for hooking
up road warriors.
This is basically
used to connect you
to another setup
someplace securely
with your own tunnel in place.
CDN, we do have a CDN.
I wouldn't, this is not like
say competitive with Akamai.
This is like you
just want to add
some edge caching to your work.
You can do that.
You set it up through
our load balancers.
They'll use HTTP headers
to determine whether or not
stuff's cached.
You can invalidate stuff.
But if you need
more advanced tools,
you probably want to go
with one of our partners
instead of just the cloud CDN.
Also DNS.
I love this, because it
irritates the lawyers whenever
I give this talk, because it
is the only product we have
that has 100% SLA.
And every single time
I give it, the lawyers
say, you can't say that.
And I was like, it says it
right there on the web page.
I'm saying it's the only product
we have that has 100% SLA.
So you can run your
DNS off of our network,
and our name
servers do have 100%
SLA, which means that
if you go with this
and we have an outage, don't
mention me in your lawsuit,
I think is what was coming
from what I just said.
Great.
All right, we're going
to move gears to storage.
So storage we basically divide
into structured or unstructured
storage.
Structured are things like data,
application data, user data.
And unstructured, things like
files and blobs and pictures
and other things.
So we'll start
with unstructured.
And we'll start
with Cloud Storage.
Cloud Storage is object
storing and serving.
If you want to have
a giant bucket where
you put all your files and
serve them up to the world,
this is the way you would do it.
Divide this kind of
into three areas--
public content, process
data and long-term storage.
So we look at the chart.
Public data, we have
at the bottom there,
multi-regional storage.
It is 99.95% available.
It's geo-redundant.
So this is for web content.
This is for stuff you
want to push to your users
as close as possible
so that they
get the fastest
pull-down of the data
that you possibly can give.
It is 2.6 gigabytes percent--
sorry, 2.6 cents per gigabyte
per month to store it there.
Now that's for
public facing data.
If you have large
data jobs, you've
got LOB files or
batch data that you
want to run a lot
of computation on,
you don't necessarily need
it close to your users.
You need it close
to the machines that
are going to do that work.
So you can go with regional,
where the data will
stay in one region, but
it's OK, because you're
going to set your VMs up there
to churn through them there.
And so they're only
going to be-- or let's
say you're just a regional,
you have a regional presence
and you don't want to
necessarily serve the world.
You can just set
up your data here.
Now, it's important to note
that just because it's regional,
doesn't mean it's only
available in that region.
It just means that it
will be faster served
in that region than
somewhere else.
It's still worldwide available
if you wish it to be.
It's cheaper. $0.02
per gigabyte per month.
And so that's regional.
Now we have two long term
storage implementations.
One is what we call Nearline,
which is 99% available.
It's got a 30-day
minimum, which means
you can put data in and
delete it in under 30 days,
but we're going to
charge you as if you
left it there the entire time.
But you can
absolutely delete it.
That's totally fine.
It's $0.01 per
gigabyte per month.
And unlike the
other ones, there is
a charge for pulling data out.
So if you envision needing
this data multiple times, what
you probably want to
do is pull it out,
leave it someplace, instead
of pulling it out repeatedly.
So it's for things like backup
or maybe long tail multimedia
that's not getting
a lot of use now,
just leave it there and
have it be stored cheaper.
The final one is Coldline,
which is our cheapest.
It's 99% available,
just like Nearline.
It's got a 90-day
minimum storage.
Again, you can pull
it out earlier,
but we'll just charge you.
And this is for things like
disaster recovery or compliance
archives, things that
you really hope you never
have to pull back out,
because if you do,
you probably have a resume
open in another window.
Disaster recovery and compliance
archive-- two things that
are not happy making.
But if you have to, at least
it's the cheapest one to store,
and you will not
kind of complain
about the $0.05 per gigabyte
to pull it out, because you've
got bigger problems.
But the incentive here
is to try to push you
towards making sure
that you're using it
the way we kind of envisioned.
This is not pulling stuff
in and out very quickly.
This is for disaster
recovery and compliance.
All right, we also
have another thing
called Cloud Filestore,
which I'm not really
going to go too much into,
because it's basically
just a managed NFS server.
If you need a file
system, if you
need multiple machines to
look at the same file system,
there you go.
We have this product.
If you need an NFS server,
this is what you need, great.
So now I'm going to
talk about SQL NoSQL.
Or actually I'm not going to
talk about SQL versus NoSQL,
because I don't want any
part of that argument.
I have my preferences.
You have your preferences.
Let's all just agree
to be friends and not
get into a NoSQL is
web scale discussion.
So we'll start with NoSQL.
We have two products here.
Cloud Datastore, which is a
horizontally scalable document
DB, and we have Cloud
Firestore, which
is a strongly-consistent
serverless document DB.
And you might, one, say I
don't think the hyphen makes
that four words, and I agree.
The other thing you might
say is, these two things,
if I look at them,
they're really similar.
They're both document DBs.
They're both
horizontally scalable
versus strongly-consistent.
All right, so what
is the difference
between these two things?
Basically, Datastore is a little
bit more capacity, a little bit
more scale, a little
bit more robust.
Firestore is based
off of Datastore,
but with the Fire base kind of
APIs on the front end, which
means, one, there's really great
connectivity to local clients.
So the SDK for writing
to mobile and web
is, I think, really, really
fantastic and easy to use.
And it has real
time capabilities.
In fact, that
network demo that I
showed where you're
seeing in real time
and hopping from
place to place, that
was powered by Firestore,
because I needed that
for the real time kind of
aspect of the experience.
OK, so then we have Cloud SQL--
Manage MySQL and PostgreSQL.
That's what it is.
It's just manage these things.
You don't have to
worry about maintenance
or you could still do all the
DBA tasks you might need to do,
but you don't really
have to do systems work
to keep that machine running.
So that's Cloud SQL.
And we have finally Cloud
Spanner, which is horizontally
scalable relational
database, which it basically
combines some of the best
features of NoSQL, which
is the fact that you
can chart it, separate
a whole bunch of
different instances,
and have that drive better
performance and better scale.
But it comes at a cost,
which is, it is not like a--
it's more of a BMW
than a Volkswagen,
if you know what I'm saying.
So if you go to
experiment with it,
please watch the pricing meter.
Because it's a great tool when
you have that level of scale
and that level of client that
you need to access or you
need to give access to, but
it is a pretty robust tool.
So how do I make the
decision of which
one to use among all of these?
Well first, it's
easy to split up.
If I've got unstructured stuff,
I want to use one of the two
on the left.
If I have structured stuff, I
want to use it on the right.
If I have pictures or
documents or other things,
how do I choose between Cloud
Storage and Cloud Filestore?
This is really easy.
Do you need a file system
and then attach it to a VM?
Then you probably
want Firestore.
If not, use Cloud Storage.
Great.
Also, if you want to share
it with the internet,
Cloud Storage is
one click to do,
whereas with Cloud Filestore,
you're dependent on the VMs
that you've run to run web
server software in order
to serve up anything
that's on there.
So I would, if you
want to share it,
Cloud Storage is
probably the way to go.
All right, so structured data.
Let's say user data or
financial transaction data
or a stack of paper,
which is, I don't know
what I was going for with that.
But you've got structured data.
If you're going with NoSQL,
if you are talking directly
between your database
and web clients,
I would highly recommend
Cloud Firestore.
If you're going a lot of
server, server communication,
Cloud Datastore is probably
the way you want to go.
And then between Cloud
SQL and Cloud Spanner,
do you have a crap ton of
users all around the world
and high needs for availability?
Well then, maybe Cloud Spanner
is the right call for you.
But you'd really have
to test it out and see
where does traditional
SQL start falling down,
and when does
Cloud Spanner start
to become worth it to you to
get the kind of performance
that you can get out of it?
So I'm going to
switch to security,
last part of infrastructure.
And one of the first
things people do,
is how do I let people in
to the resources they want?
And you use Cloud
IAM to do that.
It's pretty basic.
You've got a list of users.
You can add permissions
and roles to them.
And that's how you do it.
The permissions and roles
definitely vary from product
to product, and they are done
on a product to product basis.
So different ones will
have different abilities
to do things.
For example, one of the
things that you can do
is create custom roles.
So you can take a whole
bunch of permissions
and combine them into
a new custom role.
But that's only available
for certain products
and certain combinations,
so keep that in mind.
We also have the ability to
do key management service.
So if you want to
host your own keys,
you can-- basically everything
on ours, in terms of data,
is encrypted by default.
The only question you have
is not whether or
not it's encrypted,
it's whether or not you
manage the keys or we do.
We'll do it by default.
We're happy to do it for you.
We also know that
trust but verify.
You're perfectly entitled
to host your own keys
and manage your own keys if
that's what you want to do.
All right, so now that's
all infrastructure,
and that's all the stuff
that you absolutely have
to have to move to the cloud.
I'm going to talk about
some of the things
that we can add to the picture,
because again, we're Google,
and we have some experience
with some of these things.
Not intelligence and not me,
but that's what we call it.
So we'll start with
data analytics.
So one of the first things
I'll show off is BigQuery.
BigQuery is this amazing tool
that allows you basically
to do very fast lookups of
large, huge, huge sets of data.
And in fact, I'm
going to do one now.
I'm going to brave the
demo gods once again.
Load.
All right, so I'm going
to open this query.
I'm going to run this query.
Now let's see.
I'm going to show options,
yeah, that's fine, good.
I'm going to run this query.
So what am I running?
I have all of Wikipedia's
LOBS loaded up.
And so I can see the requests
for everything that's come in.
And I can-- oh no,
it's not using cache.
So this is going
to take a while.
I'm just going to explain
what I was going to do.
Basically, long
story short, I can
in a relatively
short period of time,
look through over a
trillion records in BigQuery
and come up with
the answer of what
are the top 100 most
searched things on Wikipedia
for 2013 and 2014.
I do know this is going to
take longer than most people's
attention spans, because I had
hoped it would remain cached.
But it didn't.
So long story short,
this allows you
to search through trillions of
records in just a few minutes,
as opposed to maybe spinning
up your own data job
and running it in
hours or whatnot.
But I am going to,
better part of valor,
and switch back to
my preso because I
have one more demo to give,
and that one I'm happy about.
So other data tools
that we have--
Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is our messaging bus.
It's a publisher
subscriber model.
You can do many to
many communication.
Basically, we can
scale to hundreds
of millions of operations,
hundreds of millions
of messages per second.
We also have Dataflow.
Dataflow is a managed
service for data analysis.
Basically, it's Apache
Beam, but managed by us.
Also managed by us
is Dataproc, which
is managed Spark and Hadoop
jobs, but with auto scaling.
So it's important to note that
Cloud Pub/Sub and Cloud Storage
form sort of a bus
so that you can--
if you need to talk between
any of our services,
that's probably going
to be one of these two
that you use to do it,
with Cloud Storage being
for unstructured data
like just a file,
whereas Cloud Pub/Sub
will do messages for you.
All right, we're going to
switch to machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
And typically we have three
kind of ways of using ML on GCP.
The first is to use our models.
The second is to create a model.
And the third is to extend
and go further with models.
So we talk about using models,
we have, some of our models
that we use the
most already exposed
in the form of these ML APIs--
Vision API, Natural
Language API, Speech API,
Translation API,
there are a few more.
But basically what
they allow you to do,
is you want to detect faces.
We have a Vision APIs that
will allow you to detect faces
in your apps--
I'm sorry, in your
pictures, because that's
a very common use case.
Same thing with logo detection
or language detection,
translation, all of that stuff.
Now typically what happens is,
someone uses this and like,
this is great and
it does this thing,
but I really wish it could
do a little bit more.
Case in point,
someone came to me
and said they wanted Vision
API, but they wanted it trained
so it could detect
whether or not
someone's face was covered,
because they wrote security cam
software and they wanted to
be able to detect someone
masked coming into a location,
because that's usually bad,
right?
We all agree.
Security, someone
coming in a mask,
they're not there for fun--
or your fun, I guess.
So we also have this thing
called Auto ML, which
takes some of our
APIs and allows
you to train your
own models, but based
within narrow constraints.
And so I'm actually
going to show one.
And it is a demo near and
dear to my heart called
Pizza Authenticator.
So I'm going to
switch over to laptop.
We're going to refresh.
And I'm going to explain.
So I was trying to
teach myself ML,
and I'm not from California.
I'm from Philadelphia.
And whenever I'm here--
I live here now--
I really don't enjoy pizza here.
And if you're from California,
you don't understand why.
And if you're not
from California,
you're nodding your head.
You understand.
So I wanted to write--
could I write something that
would detect whether or not
pizza was authentic?
Like if it said it
was New York style,
it is New York style pizza.
If it's Chicago style,
it's Chicago style.
So we're going to see
here on my desktop.
I'm going to pull up a picture.
And here we go.
So this pizza comes
from my local pizza
place that is very authentic.
Like I think it's very
good for this area pizza.
So I'm going to go ahead
and upload a picture of it.
There we go.
And we have an auto ML model
that's going to go look at it.
First it's determining whether
or not it's pizza or not.
And then after it figures out
that it is, in fact, pizza,
it should give me a score.
And it says wow, that is
95% New York style pizza.
That is good pizza, at
least according to me.
I was able to train this model
without any ML knowledge.
I was able to just take
pictures, classify them,
put them in.
And it wasn't that
tremendously hard.
And now I have my
own Auto ML model
that can determine whether or
not I'm going to like pizza.
If you want to play
with this, this
is also in the Developer Zone.
You can go, and we have at
various times that we're not
announcing, we're
bringing in actual pizza.
And when there's
not actual pizza,
you can use it with
pictures of pizza
which, we know where
they came from.
But you can play with it and
kind of see how this works.
It's also a GitHub
project, so you
can go and download it and
build your own model and play.
If want to rate other
tools, other regional foods,
you can do that.
It's cool.
I'm going to switch back to
the preso and close it out.
So if you want to
go further and not
train a narrowly
constrained model,
you probably want
to use TensorFlow,
and Cloud ML Engine
is probably the way
to do that on our platform.
It's scalable.
It's managed TensorFlow where
we will make recommendations
on how to run those jobs.
All right, so we're
at the conclusions,
and I'm close on
time, but I'm there.
So there are a ton
of GCP products.
So we weren't here.
We only showed these products.
We didn't show everything.
And here, we only showed these.
I didn't get into all of it.
But my hope is that
now you have a better
idea of where the tools are
and what kind of problems
you can solve with
them, and certainly
to compute at another level,
you can get to the resources
that you need.
So with that, I'll say thank
you very much for coming.
Your feedback, you probably
got email spamming you to say,
please rate your sessions.
I apologize, but if you
would, that would be great.
And I'm going to say thank you.
I hope you enjoy the rest of
Next, and have a good day.
I'll stick around for questions,
but I'm at the end of my time.
[APPLAUSE]